Hi
One,
welcome to toxic Google today.
It is my absolute pleasure to welcome Steve Martino,
Craig shelter and Karen Disher for the peanuts movie.
Thank you so much for joining us today.
Um,
I would love to talk about,
so this is such a huge kind of responsibility,
you know,
bringing peanuts into 2015 and into 3-d.
Um,
so I'd love Steve to know,
you know,
how,
how did you feel about this responsibility and working with Craig and working
with the,
you know,
the Shults legacy?
Well,
working with Craig has been fantastic,
but after our first meeting,
I was honored that,
uh,
he wanted to work with me on the film,
but as I went home I was like,
oh my gosh,
this is,
this is a huge responsibility.
A peanut is a big part of it.
It's like woven into the fabric of our lives.
And I grew up with a TV special,
you know,
the Christmas special in particular,
I think it was six years old when that first at the air.
Um,
it was a big deal.
And so,
you know,
as I got back to blue sky,
the wonderful thing is that people started lining up at my door.
It's like,
I,
you don't understand,
I need to work on this movie because,
and everybody's got a peanut story,
you know,
whether it was a snoopy or a certain character that they connected with.
Uh,
so what I found as I arrived back at blue sky where a team of people who kind of
joined me and taking on that responsibility,
but we kind of made a commitment to do our very best to uphold,
you know,
the wonderful tradition that peanuts has.
Okay.
Um,
as you mentioned,
your,
everyone kind of has a peanut story and uh,
Craig,
I'd love to know for you where,
where it came in,
you know,
you were screen a store,
a screen writer on this.
Um,
what,
what part of your experience growing up with a peanuts kind of came into play in
making this film?
Well,
yeah,
I have your see now,
my,
you,
my dad had over 50 specials and a lot of specials people have never seen before.
He did a live action with animation before and some other stuff.
So my son had gone to a film school and he became a screenwriter.
And in the process while he was doing a screen writing,
I'd worked on a couple of previous projects.
One was happiness is a warm blanket,
which has a direct to DVD special if it came out a while ago.
And then the probably the last TV special we did,
which is,
um,
he's a bully Charlie Brown based on a marble store that my dad had always wanted
to do.
So from that I had,
I was,
uh,
in the wall one Christmas and I heard this song,
Snoopy's Christmas,
which is from the old world guardsmen album.
And uh,
within that I had a vision of what that would look like,
animated.
And I thought,
why Sunday it'd be really cool if I can animate this thing turned into a TV
special.
And from that I kind of grew,
grew,
grew until we met Steve and blue sky and blew it out into a full blown movie.
And Karen,
I'd love to know a,
it's peanuts is story panels and story is a very visual medium already.
But you've got your drawing from,
you know,
65 years' worth of work.
Uh,
what was it
like kind of taking on that task of starting being the first step of translating
this onto the screen?
It was terrifying.
I mean,
really it was the most intimidating thing I've ever done in my life.
Not only from,
you know,
being a fan as a kid growing up with it,
not even imagining one day I'd get paid to like draw these iconic characters,
but then to not mess it up.
You know what I mean?
I think that's been everyone's mantra at blue sky through this whole process is
don't mess it up.
Don't mess it up.
Like please,
we can't mess it up.
So yeah,
it was,
um,
I mean,
especially our first,
you know,
we did all these trips up to Santa Rosa to work in the Schulz compound and you
know,
collaborate together and you've got all the drawings of the characters up on the
wall.
And here I am sitting at a table across from Craig Schultz and here's my paper
and my pencil announce like,
okay,
draw Charlie,
Charlie Brown.
I'm like,
Oh God,
please don't judge me.
You know?
And,
and the first few drawings I felt were horrible,
but Craig was very generous and very nice and Oh,
good job,
that looks great.
I'm like,
ah,
it's still probably took me a year to relax,
um,
to where I just felt like,
okay,
I can just draw them and it's,
and it's cool and,
and no one will kill me.
So,
and those first weeks we were working with paper,
I mean,
so much of our storyboard work now was on San teaks and digital,
but our first trips up there to Santa Rosa,
we got out of the story pads,
markers,
uh,
and there was no undue delete.
You go to draw Charlie Brown and you start and fail.
It's a fail.
Uh,
I'd love to talk about the kind of drawing style of it because there was,
there's this wonderful element of it.
Where do we see as it's a three d film,
but it doesn't necessarily,
it's not in your face.
It's very,
it felt very true to the poses.
The characters I love,
like they're either profile or a profile or they're like head on.
And I think my favorite kind of little visual touches all the little like two d
kind of accents.
Um,
can you guys talk about sort of developing that for it?
Was it a technological challenge or was it just like,
we got to have this in here.
Let's figure out how to do it with just super easy and it wasn't super easy.
Uh,
you
know,
what are the key when it comes from is that I thought there was an opportunity
with computer animation to,
you know,
create the world in a way that would be rich.
And yet it needed to be on style with what sparky Charles Schultz,
uh,
drew.
And so I knew walking into this that I'm asking the world peanuts fans who are
going to go really see,
gee,
I don't know about that.
Uh,
so we went overboard to make certain that everything we did in terms of our
animation style or posing a,
one of the mantras I had is I want to find the pen line in everything we do.
Even though we're using computer animation,
you can see in the style that we've chosen for Charlie Brown renamed the other
characters.
You can see that little wiggly pen line in his mouth or little ink droplets for
eyes.
And that was a very purposeful decision to say,
we're asking the audience to walk with us into,
you know,
a three d presentation in this film.
We need to be very well anchored in everything else that we do in pose and
animation.
Uh,
even in the way we handled textures and materials.
I actually would love to talk about the textures and materials because they
were,
so,
it's,
this is such a nerdy thing,
but they were so like tech,
like I tangible almost like I felt like they'd be like a little fuzzy if I
touched them,
but then the clothing felt very kind of realistic and the hair was very
appropriate for the style.
Um,
and it,
I don't know if it's necessarily something that has been in blue sky films
before.
Did you guys kind of revamp that process a bit?
Or?
We did.
We actually ratcheted when it comes to materials,
we ratcheted ourselves back and said,
you know,
this is a particular style for this movie.
The character silhouettes have to stand out first and foremost.
I want to see the silhouette of that Charlie Brown pose.
Uh,
but we thought,
well,
we can add a little something.
And I saw somebody brought up there Beagle and uh,
that is one of the,
one of the reasons that I thought it would be exciting to use computer animation
to see snoopy with soft for many people came up to me and their memory of a
peanuts came from a plush toy.
You know,
and I thought if we could bring the characters to life and have some of that
softness and tactile quality,
but what it required is that the texture is always sit back a little bit.
It's a matter of fact,
we got partway through the film and we were evaluating how the characters looked
against the backgrounds.
And we,
I kind of reoriented our thinking to say,
look,
we need to just kind of pull back.
So stylistically,
everything felt like it was in the same style and world.
I thought one moment where the three d and the camera work also complimented
the,
the new style very well was the,
uh,
aviation sequences.
Uh,
and I,
I was curious as to kind of,
they're very different than the kind of grounded in the real world of Charlie
Brown.
What was the approach to those,
the flying a sequences?
Well,
it comes from the comic strip.
I'll tell you everything in this movie.
Uh,
it,
the roots of any decision that we may comes from the comic strip.
And as we,
you know,
spend time in Santa Rosa had looked through,
looked at original strips and we had access to all of the comic strips.
Uh,
if you look at any of the,
a flying ace or any of the fantasy sequence or fantasy comic strips that Charles
Schultz drew,
he drew with more perspective.
All of a sudden you see roads going back,
you know,
into depth.
Uh,
there was a lot more ink,
you know,
in detail you'd see cobblestones and you know,
it just was a richer presentation in that pending style.
So for me,
I thought,
well,
here's the opportunity to unhinge the camera,
you know,
have a camera language that was more diagonals and dimensional and,
and more camera movement because we're in Snoopy's imagination.
And the comic strip was kind of suggesting that.
And then Charlie Brown's world,
it's a more kind of formal composition that really is derived from the comic
strip.
Okay.
You're an aviator.
You not,
well yeah,
for 40,
40,
50 years,
something like that.
But the original concept for the movie was,
it was called snoopy first.
The Red Baron original concept I had had was to take Johnny Brown's world,
which is classic to d right out of the Christmas special sorta.
I'll look.
And then my fantasy was to anything blend into the CG world.
So when I first started presenting the idea and I went to blue skies,
I knew they'd be able to handle the CG portion was they said,
well,
we don't do two d.
I'm like,
okay,
I have the friends the problem.
But Steve saw that problem with camera angles.
And so when you're in a Brown's world,
cause these two worlds dovetail together,
you already feel like you're looking at the comic strip to camera,
doesn't panel place.
It's not a lot of movement.
And even said from the camera up cycle,
is this,
all I gotta do is just stick the camera,
leave it there on this.
That's sort of what it was until we get a snoopy Snoopy's mine.
And I think the unique thing is once you're in Snoopy's world,
we actually finally get to see what Snoopy's thinking.
And we see soupy flying,
the Halloween special and so forth.
We seem in the common,
but we've never really seen what goes on in his mind.
And this movie gave us a chance to Rudy,
you know,
see what snoopy really thinks and how this crazy dog and visualize the world.
And that was really exciting from a camera standpoint and a movie standpoint.
And from my writing standpoint,
everybody opened it up.
Well,
the most fun,
Craig owns a biplane.
And early in the journey,
he took me up in that by plane.
It's say,
okay,
here's what the dog fights like.
And we went up and we did stalls,
we did loops.
And there was amazing things that I learned from that just from us,
an audio perspective.
Like when you go up on a stall,
the sound,
the engine just cuts out and you go flying down anyway.
Uh,
that helped.
And then to be honest and be authentic,
we had,
you know,
Skywalker sound found out that I,
Craig has a biplane,
oh,
can we record that?
So we had Skywalker sound come out and we had Mike's put on the airplane,
on the engine,
on the outside.
We've got 10 people on the ground and we did a bunch of low passes and I had a
girl in the cockpit,
don't all they are bad.
So we've got all the doppler effect sounds.
And uh,
they were thrilled and we did a lot of authentic sounds within the movie.
I think that most creative when we did the movie opens,
you'll see a pin line go across the screen.
And,
uh,
what we did is we had our art director take the original pen that my dad used
and his age and his original paper used and I,
Lucas San went up and recorded those pin line movements that are just exactly
like my dad would have done as he's drawing the comic strip and we'd recorded
ice skates,
says kids skate thrashy ice skating sounds from my dad's ice arena put into the
movie.
So a lot of Nice little touches like that.
Um,
I'd love to know,
and Karen it actually like to hear your thoughts on this first because I think
it would probably be the easiest to kind of get,
oh,
I don't want to say like trapped in the shadow of but,
but keep reusing the original material as reference.
But you guys are obviously bringing your own kind of story to this.
So I'd love to know for you,
what was it like kind of striking a balance between the classic imagery of the
original comics and then sort of your
guys' own take on it?
Yeah,
that was definitely really hard,
especially for me.
Like I was saying like it was intimidating just wanting to draw the characters.
Exactly right,
exactly.
On model,
which when you're doing storyboarding for a feature that's typically not um,
really productive cause you kinda gotta work fast.
You know,
it's a very,
the work of a storyboard artists is to just Redo,
Redo,
Redo your,
just the first line of,
of the work.
You're testing things out.
If they don't work,
you know,
you didn't spend two months animating something,
you spent maybe a day or two and you can just throw it away.
So you got to work fast.
But I would just,
I mean honestly,
I'll,
I'll confess,
I just traced for probably the first month or two,
I would go to the website,
find a Charlie brown pose and then just,
okay,
at least I know I'm not,
again,
disrespecting the tradition and the memory and the heritage or doing something
crazy.
And then I started to realize that that was really paralyzing me and not
enabling me to do my job the way I should,
which is to be thinking of new stuff and thinking of gags and like pushing the
envelope.
So I finally got over it and relaxed and I was like,
okay,
his head's not perfect here,
but it still looks like Charlie Brown.
So it was tricky.
It was tough.
It was not like any other thing I've worked on.
But,
uh,
it was awesome.
I think also from a story perspective,
we wanted to strike this balance of a,
there can be moments for fans where you're like,
oh,
I remember something like that from before,
but we didn't want the movie to be just a collection of a greatest hits from the
past.
It's a feature film.
Craig and Brian and a Neil Giuliano,
the writing team,
you know,
craft at a feature film story with narrative drive,
character arc,
you know,
a real feature story.
The characters are,
you know,
they're based on the characters we know.
So those,
those things don't change.
Uh,
and if now and again we might intersect into a moment that we remember from the
comic strip,
you know,
that's a nice little added beat.
But there were,
you know,
the story is new.
So there are a lot of new things in there as well.
But you know,
we also,
um,
we really did push the envelope at times cause we would get beat together in
Santa Rosa.
It was usually a,
myself,
our head of story,
Jim Cameroon,
our animation supervisor,
Nick Bruno,
and we definitely did what animators do and you know,
Nick would jar Charlie brown naked and we,
you know,
put in a toilet gag and we all knew that none of these would see the light of
day,
nor should they,
but it's still,
you kind of get it out of your system and you have fun with it and it just kind
of helps you loosen up.
All in all.
That's where Craig came in.
Yes.
That's when Craig learned that,
say the word no over and over and over again.
And he was always right.
Um,
I think one wonderful way though that you guys have kind of honored the
tradition of it is bill Melendez is the voice of snoopy.
Oh yeah.
And uh,
how,
how did you guys do?
Well,
Craig and I made that trip down to his,
to his office.
Yeah.
That was something I already wanted to do when it,
when we're talking about the voices and it hadn't come up yet.
And as we talked about snoopy and Woodstock and so forth,
I said,
would it be cool if we could get bill a credit in the movie?
You know,
so we call Melendez studio.
Steve and I went over there when we dug in to their archives and found out
already how much stuff they had saved over the years of bill being snoopy and
Woodstock.
And we had enough material to put in the movie and craft all the voices that we
needed.
So that was phenomenal.
I,
and I'm already proud that we did that for bill.
Well,
and it's,
I love honoring bill,
but when we put those clips into our first story reels,
there's no way we could have created anything as funny as charming.
He was amazing.
Uh,
you know,
they're just sounds that he,
that snoopy makes,
it's like comedy gold and there was no reason to recreate it.
And we worked with Randy Tom.
He figured the formula out.
Randy works at Skywalker sound.
Um,
you know,
so we could have if need be recreated.
But thankfully we use bill and you know,
we all go through our lives and come across one or two people that you will
never forget and blow bill minuses,
one of those type people.
He was so big and bolster us and had his big mustache.
He was always happy and it's like anyone that met bill would never forget bill.
He was a tremendous person.
He passed away a couple years ago.
But uh,
I remember when I was like 10 years old,
he took me out shotgun shooting trap shoot.
And he was tremendous.
A trap shooting.
And I've never forgotten that.
50 years later I still remember going trap shooting with a bill.
And then can you talk a little bit about the Ed,
the new boys cast because you've got some wonderful young actors and yes,
I couldn't be more proud of a,
of the group of actors,
all kids and where it starts,
Craig and I talked about this at the very beginning.
You know,
Charlie Brown for me was Charlie Brown from the Christmas special.
Linus was Linus from the Christmas special,
the Halloween special,
those voices imprinted on me.
And as there were specials that came later as a kid even,
I'd be like,
well that's not quite the Charlie Brown.
And you know,
that I remember.
So it was one of the things I was most nervous about.
And in particular I was nervous about as casting a Linus because Linus has this
beautiful little list and a Christian Kaplan who's our casting director,
scoured the country,
thousands of audition tapes.
Thankfully I didn't have to listen to all of,
you know,
thousands of them.
He narrowed them down.
Uh,
but I'm so happy with the voices that we've found and,
and the objective was to try to match the cadence,
the rhythm and the kind of vocal timber of,
uh,
of those original characters.
And when we found Linus with that list,
I'm like,
oh my gosh.
He came to blue sky,
uh,
two weeks ago.
And,
uh,
they were just touring him around the studio because often we do our recording
outside of our studio and he was walking around the state.
Every animator,
it's like,
oh,
say something.
Say Charlie Brown,
they just wanted to hear Linus,
his voice.
Yeah.
It is amazing.
I mean,
I was fresh off the blanket movie where we had to do the casting and I
discovered that the best way to get oh dish and the kids was not having to come
in and read lines in the Christmas special Halloween special.
The best way was to have them come in and simply introduce themselves,
tell me what school they go to,
what grade they're in,
what their hobbies are,
and invariably when we cast that movie and this movie within,
I say no more than five words.
I knew if they were right or wrong and you just start chucking them out.
Nope,
nope,
nope.
When they get in the acting,
acting,
it's a little different because then a lot of people can mimic stuff and parody
stuff,
but when you,
you want them to just kind of be genuine,
heartfelt,
and not do much acting in our kids I think are spot on.
Everybody's seen the movies where they said,
boy,
those that cast,
it's dead on.
You know?
It's interesting working with kids and I love working with kids.
I've coached soccer my entire life.
And uh,
what is amazing is they have such rich imaginations.
When we record,
we don't have any footage,
uh,
because we're recording the voices and then we animate to those voices and then
the movie starts to take shape.
So I'm asking any actor to go on a journey with me in a room that has just four
walls and a microphone,
and we talk about what this scenario is,
what's going on.
And they were amazing in the way that they could imagine themselves there and
create.
It's like,
it was so good,
easy for them.
Um,
but it was good fun though.
Recording sessions where a great time.
The other cool thing,
there's a little bit of Trivia there is that the movie's called the peanuts
movie by Schultz and I,
and the by Schultz is important because there's four generations is Schultz
solvency.
90% of the movie comes from my dad's comic strip.
Then there's myself,
his son,
and his grandson,
which is my son.
But beyond that,
there's this great grandson is the voice of a little character.
We call it little kid that's a little kindergartener,
good character.
And he was cool because his voice is distinctly different than the rest of the
kids in the movie.
You recognize that this isn't a voice I've heard before.
And uh,
it was fun putting anything into the film.
Um,
I think one of my last questions for you is,
um,
why do you think we need Charlie Brown in this day and age and what is one of
the things that you were most excited for audiences to kind of connect with with
this new film?
Tell you,
for me,
and I've grown to appreciate Charlie Brown so much more.
Uh,
what I love about what Craig and Brian and Neil did is they looked at the,
you know,
50 years of Charlie Brown said,
well,
you know,
what are the qualities that he has?
There were comic strips off and where he had to put up with Sally,
his nagging,
you know,
little sister.
And,
and from that,
we've got a wonderful theme in the story where we get to hold up the qualities
that he's always had,
that Charlie Brown is kind,
he's honest,
and most of all,
he perseveres.
He's the guy that never wins that baseball game,
that kite never flies.
But he picked himself back up and he tries again and he became kind of the,
uh,
the spirit of the making of this movie,
at least for me.
You know,
when,
when we were trying to work on something,
you know,
we would have one of those failures like,
oh,
that doesn't look right.
Or,
you know,
I go home.
It's like,
oh,
we're going to do this.
If it was a bad day,
I'd put on my Charlie Brown sweatshirt the next day.
It's like,
today's a day we're going to win the game.
Yeah.
I don't think the very first day I went back to blue sky and we just met with
Steve and so forth that we had the whole blue sky team came in and asked him the
same question.
I said,
how many of you,
the audience think the Charter Brenda's bald?
And probably 60% of the people put their hands.
If I thought,
oh my God,
I'm in trouble already.
And then we got to design Charlie Brown.
But I think I kind of led sort of a charter brown light because we knew the son
of a celebrity,
for example,
you have a lot of people come to your house,
your kids are coming to all of the time.
You always got to ask yourself,
you know,
do they really like me for who I am?
Or do they like we just because of being around Neil Sparky's house and the
swimming pool,
everything else and the journey and Charlie Brown,
he's,
he's dealing with that same thing,
which we all deal with.
Am I like to people like me for who I am and so forth.
So we explored that journey and,
and Charlie Brown's world of what it would be like.
I also was interested in the journey with how people see yourselves and see each
others as,
as small children when they see each other.
You know,
I remember being in third grade and seeing this girl and I'd literally felt like
I was in love when I was in third grade and I look at third graders now and
there are these little tiny think,
how could I possibly have been in love with third grade?
But those little kids have those complex feelings.
And that's again,
when my dad expressed in the comic strip and we kind of carried that theme in at
the movie that they do have those complex thoughts and a very adult little,
there is small,
big heads.
I think for me,
um,
why we still need Charlie Brown very much is he's,
he's a,
he's just a good guy.
Like when you walk out of the movie,
you have this,
um,
it just has a very timeless feeling.
You know,
you're not in the modern day,
you're not like a hundred years ago.
It just kinda feels timeless.
And he is just someone you either know or you are,
you know,
we all try for things and fail as,
as Craig and Steve said,
but,
but he's,
he's just a good guy and there's not snark in this movie,
you know,
there's not pop culture references.
Um,
it's just,
it's just a very,
in a way,
a very simple and plain story.
You know,
he's not going to go to another planet and like save the Galaxy,
but what kid is,
you know,
and,
and so it's a very aspirational movie in a,
in a different way.
You know,
it's,
it's going to tell every kid who has a bad day.
Like,
you know,
it's all right because I was a good guy at the end of the day,
you know.
So we have time for just a few audience questions and Kevin here is going to ask
them on behalf of the Internet and hello.
So,
um,
I want to start with all three of you.
And so what is,
which is your favorite character and why?
And Karen,
maybe,
which one was your favorite to work with?
And also,
uh,
Craig,
maybe talk about also,
um,
who your father's favorite character was to write for.
Okay.
Well,
I mean I think from a pure animation,
snoopy is going to be where you can have the most freedom,
you know,
freedom of movement and the craziness of the,
the stuff he can do that you just can't do with 'em or shouldn't do.
Maybe the human characters.
But yeah,
free snoopy is just pure animation and what stocks really fun to do too.
Like he,
people kind of forget about them as the little side,
but he's,
he's so much fun.
And then you get the Eagle Scouts in there and it's this group of little birds
and the possibilities are endless.
And uh,
some of the snoopy Woodstock scenes in the,
in the movie or the best,
in my opinion,
they're just cause there's no dialogue.
You can't use it as a crutch.
You can't like send it in for punch up for new funny lines.
It's like pure just action and gags and slapstick and fun.
Yeah.
I think for me,
I think as it was almost profound for me is it as Steve's team got the animation
done?
Yeah.
We have characters from the very first comic strip.
We have suremy,
we have violent,
we have patty,
we have all the classical characters and I literally fell in love with him all
over again because of the way you see it now in three d and Cgi,
they become much more identifiable and the movie,
I love Sally,
I've always loved salary.
I think she's,
she's hilarious and and so forth.
Then a funny Sally stories,
we were casting the voice.
I walked in and they didn't know who I was.
It was my first time out to,
uh,
to watch some voices been record and she was sitting there on the island said,
I said,
I saw your,
you're playing Sally.
She says,
yes.
I said,
we'll keep,
can you read me off?
One of the lines from the Christmas special and she just went into the speech
and she could do the full blown every line from the Christmas social she had
memorized and you just rattled them out and certain she,
her name is Mary,
and she was just phenomenal to work with.
And uh,
later on she found out who I was,
but uh,
that was fun.
Give her a little bit of stage and she'll fill it up.
She's gone.
Yeah.
And the second part of the question was maybe who your father's favorite
character was to write for.
I never liked to speak for what my father would have thought and,
and so forth.
All I can say is that for the most part,
my dad will typically say that most of his personality,
he was Charlie Brown,
Charlie Martin,
who we,
who is what,
who he was.
And snoopy was who he would've liked to have been.
I mean,
the fantasy the snoopy has,
I think we all have these fantasies.
And I,
my dad obviously live in that same kind of world and that's probably the easy
way to sum it up.
He was really,
every character was a piece of my dad at some level.
But I think the majority of my dad,
this is Charlie Brown,
which is not a bad thing to say.
Um,
and Steve,
uh,
did you guys ever consider a different type of animation for this?
I know blue skies,
obviously a 3-d stew,
you know,
CGI studio,
but any ever consider stop motion or two D for this?
No,
but we added a lot of two d animation to the movie.
Uh,
so matter of fact,
when I'm,
some of my favorite moments in the film,
a Charlie Brown,
whenever he imagined dreams,
a little thought bubble will pop up.
It's all two D it looks to me,
I always say it's the,
it's the daily strip.
So it's black and white.
It's done in pen and ink.
Uh,
to me it's some of the nicest peanuts animation,
uh,
ever done because it really looks like Sparky's pen line come to life.
Uh,
and we ended up adding a lot more two d then I think we ever thought we would,
uh,
starting in the movie.
So there's always lots of little speed lines,
you know,
uh,
Lucy gets bonked on the head with a typewriter and of course you have to have
those little flowery bonks and type,
ah,
graphy uh,
so there's plenty of two d mixed in with the 3-d.
Um,
but you know,
our paintbrush.
And,
and I felt that there was something we could do with three d that would bring
this world to life in a,
in a different way.
I,
he did and he did a wonderful job.
There's a transitioning now Charlie Brown's world to be Santa World,
which we struggle with for a while.
And Steve would back in the studies what Melendez had done it again.
We've,
not only did he go to my dad's comic strip,
we also did a lot of,
and Melendez and Melendez had these phenomenal color backgrounds,
almost psychedelic stuff from the 70s.
He put it in there and Steve's team find a way to blend that.
And with three d it really looks wonderful.
So your,
um,
your slides show a lot of analysis that I've not seen before.
Are you going to have a tie in with the Shults museum so that you can present
some of the analysis,
whether that's the historical change through time,
it was a really nice layout or how are,
you know,
how is,
how are the characters laid out on the page?
I've never seen that before,
although I've looked at all this trips.
Right.
What's your tie in with the museum?
There's an exhibition that's up right now at the museum that has even a few of
the slides that are from my presentation.
You know,
it's kind of done up in museum style,
uh,
kind of talking about,
some of the journey and uh,
they've,
they've done a wonderful interactive,
a part of the museum as well that's kind of tied into the movie.
And I've done a couple of talks.
I gave a talk there.
Well,
we had a whole team,
a whole panel.
Karen was there.
Uh,
we were there two weeks ago,
I think it was a,
and did a panel and I had done a similar kind of presentation to all of their
major donors.
The museum is such a part of this journey for us.
So,
um,
yeah,
maybe there'll be more after that.
Yeah,
that's for those of you who haven't been up there,
we just had an exhibit called animating comics,
which kind of showed how the early stuff was done and then that transitioned
into the blue sky exhibit.
Right now we're sort of just putting up right now we have a couple of great
photo op things where you can literally get on the dog house and behind you it's
going to be the Eiffel Tower,
the clouds and get a nice picture yourself.
Sit down and Snoopy's dog house,
which is a full blown three d model they made up there.
It's a,
it's a beautiful exhibit being installed at this time.
So come on up to Santa Rosa,
see us.
Um,
so I have so many fond memories of the music from the specialist and I'd love to
hear some of your thoughts about,
uh,
how you planned or,
how you,
uh,
decided on musical choices for the movie.
You know,
it follows the overriding objective for the film,
which was,
uh,
this is a new story,
but based on characters we've loved,
uh,
we want moments that are those touchstones for fans.
And so,
you know,
first and foremost,
a Christoph back was our composer on the film.
And as a,
I spoke with him as we discussed the music for the movie,
first and foremost,
the mute the music needed to support the storytelling.
Uh,
but that said,
there are moments that we have jazz combo.
You,
you can't have a movie like this without Linus and Lucy theme.
So we have Vince Guaraldi [inaudible] original performance,
you know,
in a couple of important moments in the film.
And then we also,
uh,
I had the chance to work with Megan trainer,
who is a contemporary artists,
uh,
and she really seemed to capture the spirit of Charlie Brown and peanuts and
wrote two original songs.
We originally,
uh,
I was working with her to write one song for the film in one particular area
that I thought she would just be right for.
And she did that and it was amazing.
And then she got to know the story.
And this Charlie Brown story just kind of sunk in with her and she wrote this
other song just out of the blue,
sent me a demo,
said,
you know,
it just came to me because I was so taken by the story.
And so make certain to stay through the early part of the credits.
Both songs are in there and kind of their full form.
Uh,
so it's been quite a mix.
You know,
there are times in the story where the f you know,
the power of a full orchestra is the way to underscore the Amo,
you know,
that particular moment.
And then there are other places where the jazz combo does it.
And then there were places where Megan trainor song actually helps service the
story.
And that was what was most important.
Thank you.
I think this is our last question.
So,
uh,
first of all,
I really would like to thank you all for doing this.
And I've been a penis fan for over 40 years.
I grew up with this and um,
I watched penis in three different languages in four different countries.
So this is a huge to me personally.
Um,
and I actually spent a whole day at the museum yesterday,
saw the beautiful exit,
got the picture done,
wearing the gear.
I'm probably always the oldest person to do that,
but I didn't care.
Uh,
I've doubted my question to you,
especially to,
to Craig.
Um,
your dad passed away in 2000 and um,
I know that he made it clear actually even in his interview that you guys
actually the children and the father agreed that there will be no more of
drawing of peanuts.
So,
um,
but now to see this,
this beautiful,
but so as an a lifetime fan,
my greatest concern for the peanuts franchise and this legacy is that how are we
going to just somehow continue this into the 21st century?
Because this is something that started in the 1940s and,
and the,
there's a generation that growing up watching this really specific like sensory
and sensory cartoons,
this is something different.
Um,
so therefore,
I think this is beautiful thing.
But also I would like to ask you,
what is the plan for this franchise?
Are you guys now the children and,
and um,
and Mrs. Schultz agreed to create more,
a little bit different stories.
Is it okay,
are you going to continue?
This is a momentum and are you going to keep going on to create more peanuts,
legacy that will be more suitable to the 21st century?
Well,
I think,
let me kind of address a couple of these things.
Uh,
number one,
as far as the commerce strip,
you know,
we,
we feel the commerce,
Europe was like the cost.
Those are you not gonna have somebody else come in and try to copy Picasso.
So,
you know,
we knew that the commerce trip was sacrosanct.
The,
and the family met with an attorney back in the 70s and we told her,
dad,
you said we don't,
you know,
did,
my dad was going to have somebody else do the common ship when he passed on and
you know,
just so have income for the family.
And the family said,
no day,
we don't want anyone at all.
This comes,
this is your work.
You've done this.
Every,
every strip,
every letter is strictly years.
We would never have somebody even thinking about drawing the comic strip.
And the other hand,
you know,
there are peanuts fans.
We all love peanuts.
We want penis to continue.
So they are becomes dilemma.
How do you continue?
How do you make peanuts continue,
you know,
without,
without doing something new with the commerce service,
again,
we've been,
we've been really blessed and lucky that all the newspapers have continued to
rise to the commerce ships.
And I find that the comic strips today or is as relevant as they were in the
1960 [inaudible] the 1950s,
the themes applied all of us,
the messages at the same,
it's all about heart and,
and,
and so forth.
Um,
when it comes to the movie,
you know,
we want to bring in a new generation.
Do you say person disappeared?
Kids that are all just,
we're working on their iPhone and IPAD.
They don't see the old content.
So the best way to do that is do you have a via creative vehicle,
it's going to drive them back to that media.
And,
and my hope for the movie,
my main hope was at the movie would be the Rock in the pond.
And the ripple effect was going to be what's going to drive all you people after
seeing the movie to wonder,
Gosh,
she's a little cruel Sally.
She just seems more interesting.
I need to know more about,
or I need to know more about [inaudible] go back and read the conscious of the
bugs and refund the message that my dad created.
Cause this is just a tiny,
tiny sampling of what that world is all about.
Thank you all so much.
And uh,
everyone go enjoy the peanuts movie and visit the penis.
There's also museum.
Thanks for joining us today.
Thank you for having us.
Oh Wow.